look I know not all fans are super
excited for a power of the doctor the
last outing for Jody Whitaker the
Centenary special but whether you're
excited for it or not uh it's a bit
weird we don't know when it's airing
you try and find out there's speculation
possibly of incredible speculation when
it's supposed to air but nothing
official from the BBC they've done zero
to Market this recent pictures that came
out uh related to it came out through
sfx magazine and Doctor Who magazine
nothing from BBC officially you've got
BBC America tweeting stuff like we're
waiting very patiently for the premiere
of the power of the doctor you know what
the rest of us are waiting for to find
out when the day even heirs
look BBC even if you think it's garbage
even if you're ashamed of it you're
clearly still going to air it so tell us
when it's going to be you're not
abandoning the property you've got
shitty gosh one lined up
so at this point it's just
infuriating and weird and even if you
try and bury it we're all going to see
it eventually just tell us what it is